[Musik]
sie klingt wieder
tange ließ meter harmonie 2 nach ihrem
lifting nach 38 jahren rattern und
knattern war die abnutzung massiv von
klang kaum noch die rede
also wurden alle hebel in bewegung
gesetzt die maschine am leben zu
erhalten und aufzufrischen
bewegung ist schließlich dank ließ
markenzeichen eine metapher für das
moderne leben wie ihr 1967 erklärte wenn
man dann so k sage ich meine schon
unendliche sinnlosigkeit wo man könnte
mal tag verliere
danke sie kreierte die mieter harmonie
zwei 1979 sie gehört zur emanuel
hoffmann sammlung die im schaulager bei
basel betreut wird in dieser institution
gegründet von miami haben die
restauratoren markus bröcker und jean
marc gaillard ein jahr lang jedes detail
dokumentiert repariert notfalls ersetzt
wie diese disney ente dank seriennummer
identifiziert und ersteigert im internet
das original irreparabel
daran vermochte auch carol matt die
dritte im bunde nichts zu ende
das ziel des forschungsprojektes die
maschine akustisch und visuell so weit
wie möglich in den originalzustand
zurück zu setzen
[Musik]
wir haben eine fotografie aus dem
fotoarchiv von leonardo bezzola und
anhand dieser farbfotografie konnten wir
einige interessante dinge erkennen zum
beispiel dass die glühbirne sitz so weit
ich denken kann eigentlich immer weiß
war ursprünglich eine gelbe behörde
gewesen ist
kleiner eingriff große wirkung nicht
gänzlich ersetzt sondern geflickt wurden
ausgeleierte gummizüge neue spannkraft
im alten kleid
ich bin stolz darauf dass die perkussion
schläge wieder jetzt mit einer gewissen
spannung und auch stärker auf die
instrumente einschlagen und in dem sinne
auch einen ganz ganz anderen klang
erzeugen
[Musik]
für stark abgenutzte metallteile hat das
team gar eine eigene technik entwickelt
diese mit kunststoff aufzufüllen
getrimmt auf alt selbst eisen
verschleißt
ganz zu schweigen von weiteren
materialien wir haben jetzt kein ersatz
gefunden für diesen schuh
deswegen haben wir versucht mit diesem
schuh so zu bewahren indem wir halt eben
eine metall sohle eingefügt haben
diese metall sohle verhindert dass sich
dieser schuh bei aufschlag überdehnt
[Musik]
wir haben überlegt einen 3d scan
anfertigen zu lassen von diesem objekt
so dass wir mit hilfe dieses gens dann
später einmal eine kopie erstellen
können und dass dann noch tanke die wäre
mehr fragen als antworten habe es
während der restaurierung gegeben
tancredi hätte sich gewundert schön
wär's schon die tägliche pflege im
museum tage lee ist eine gewaltige
herausforderung
jean marc gaillard auf seinem
morgendlichen rundgang
fünf jahre lang hat cayard anke die
persönliche assistiert kratz nicht sagen
wie stolz ich kann nicht beweisen
ich weiß ganz genau wie es dazu kommt
dass das das curry hat erfuhr man
machine eine besondere beziehung
und wenn sie krank sind und die an einem
regentag und dennoch muss man halt sagen
da geht es derweil dass wir jetzt wieder
alles anrichten als hinterhalt
aber eigentlich geht es allerdings die
macher alte kranke dann wird das pausen
intervall verlängert ein objekt
schlimmstenfalls aus dem verkehr gezogen
durch die integration ist dass das
netzwerk 100 hinter das muss ich noch
machen
der tägliche verschleiß nichts für die
ewigkeit hinausgeschoben werden muss
jetzt erst einmal die reparatur denn die
meta harmonie 2 ist eingetroffen
aus dem schaulager als dauerleihgabe ich
danke sich jetzt gut dass jetzt model
quasi ins rennboot eine extra stunde
zeit notruf dieser misst die laufzeit
und liefert so anhaltspunkte wie schnell
sich einzelne teile abnutzen wie lange
es dauern wird bis wieder gehandelt
werden muss mitten im aufbau schaut
seppi im hof vorbei er hat mit jan o die
tonmischung schiene einst gebaut
imhof kannte tage dies macken und laune
ist abfall für mich es ist hinter mir
geht wahrscheinlich war das selbst
versprach glück doch jetzt provoziert
auch erzählt während enkelin mit diesem
lifting also einverstanden gewesen
schon ab
freiwillig hat sehr große freude sagt
sie klingt genauso wie damals für das
glauben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
o